ぽん酢味噌場です a
褒められたい
僕は褒められたい仏教に思ってしまいました
というわけで今日はあのはじめ冊を食べたら褒めようという動画でございますよろしく
お願いしますみなさん褒められたら嬉しくないですか
僕は
嬉しいですあの結局も人っていうのはね褒められたら嬉しいですよ
褒められたら誰だって気持ち良くなっちゃうわけなんですよねそれ言ったらもう思う
存分褒められってどこまでも気持ちよくなってやろうじゃねーかって言うと考える
ちょっとどうとって言っていこうと思います人というのは2種類に分けられると思うん
ですよ
褒められて伸びる人と貶されて伸びる人僕は
貶されての二手法ですねたぶんねこうね褒められると猫得られていい気分になっちゃっ
て調子乗っちゃうよ僕ターボ貶されたり窮地に立たされると頑張れるタイプの人間です
けど今日だけはちょっと褒められようかなと思いまして今日褒められる動画でござい
ますみなさん込めてくれませんか
お願い子もいっぱいいたけど褒めて箱というのがありまして
twitter と連携してできるやつなんです
のまずは褒めて箱を作成して皆にお伝えしましょう
私褒められると伸びますもっと褒めてください
正直すぎませんかねすごい正直なんでもねやっぱね人ってさ
誰でもそうだと思うんですけども褒めるとねー
ってなっつーわけなんですよね今日はもうと異なる褒められ続けるとどれだけキモツ
いいのかなと思ってた選びに溺れてみようと思いますこの本見てばを策定してみんなに
伝える押せばタブついてされるのではないでしょうか
皆さんにお伝えしましたたくさん褒めてもらいましょうそれぞれを得られるのかの旅
社長のホビてロコ
私はほぼへしゅっと飛びますもっと褒めてください
恥ずかしいのこれこれで僕はどこが食べられるのでしょうか
褒められたい
もう一軒きてるもうこれ6人が俺のことを褒めてるってことだよね上げがて褒められ
たい見たい
62から来てくるレターでタッチしても反応しないから京都します込められた言われて
ハゲるぞ位
[音楽]
フェア
反応しなくなっちゃったを得られないのに何で何で何も出なくなっつってなんだこれ
バグかやばいバグった終わったらなんだこれなんでだよを得られないのだから
いやぁなんでなんで女なんかしたっけなんだかサーバーを過ぎたのかな
褒めてはを見れないんですけど2分パスロボ食べれないですねちょっとパソコンで見て
みましょう
[音楽]
だめだサーバーを通じてんだこれ多分もっと褒めてネットが開けなくなっちゃったよね
まってまってこれをやばいじゃん
褒められないじゃんちょっとサーバーをせ切れ様おおっつできるわけないんで1回
ツイート削除しますこれ俺のせいかな
これオルグ制度と分あきたぷきた入れます入りました
やったツイート削除して多分見てくれベルトが減ったんでこれで魅力
褒められることができますってもう99球も切れる
もう来てるとてもお安いですね
ドンッ
ップを右手はない始め言えないよ
おなんかねこれはねそういう一言だけでまで嬉しくなって好きなことをして生きている
感じが好きだしかっこいいと思います
[音楽]
を際世紀末並みに隔月とよくわかんないいつもがんばっててないよ
願ったねこれ嬉しいなあこれなんだか嬉しいないつも撮影とか編集とかお疲れ様えらい
えらい
[音楽]
メセナ
なんだこれかみ合っていいかいます優しいところとかっこいいところとたまにバカなと
ことが魔女めなとたくさん笑うとこ
笑顔素敵なところ私のリップに反応してくれるとこう
あなたのすべてが大好きですいっぱいチキってやつかないつも一生懸命なところが
大好きです一番数機パンマン
届い坊主と込めてもをパンバー一君ポケモンに立てる絶対
熱顔も体つきも3つそっくりなんだな水と弾みビール買ってる
何言ってやんた a ラインすぐ投げやりに言われてる感じがすごいすると自分河芸
みたいな顔でめっちゃいいと思う
あえて褒めない込めてや耳が可愛い
ソースか
そう彼が初めて女性物の理想の男性の姿だったりしない
性がた時だったままよくて優しくて面白くてかっこよくてすこし抜けてるところがあっ
て
かまってあげたくなるような人だよねすごい外れすごいね
損切りするよ
[音楽]
恥ずかしい少しでいっぱいなところが好きです
男ですが掘りたいですよろしくお願いしますします許してください
日本語を教える時のはじめかっこよすぎと変質がしたので時間のある時に少しずつ動画
を見てますありがとうございます
何入れないありがとうございますいいね
東京静岡を日本一移動しているとですねその通りかもしれません
ありがとう前継ぐものを押すれる曲なかなか真似できません
this じゃないのかこれははじめかっこいいありがとうございます今でマックだよ
羨ましいねやさを過ぎます一さんありがとうございます施工ありがとうございますじゃ
ないぞありがとうございます可愛いありがとうございます身長高いありがとうござい
ます会編集して以来ねありがとうござ
ほめでね込めてください月かっこいいかわいいよ弾めばエライエライん神アプリあこの
アプリ気持ちすごいまずでずっと大丈夫が褒めてくれるぞこれが弾み君いつも言っても
消しお疲れ様ですえらいえらいよく頑張りました
いつもかっこいいよイケメンカッコいいねぇ初音ミクかわいいよ
左をはじめもかっこいいお揃い好きぴよ子要素えらいえらい
田治米かっこいいスタイル抜群発目 stp 味雌子も居ボルトの最強を関係なくね
ん
me
バッハ